des responsables de médecins sans
frontières qui n'était pas au départ
convaincus du bien fondé de l'opération
turquoise sont extrêmement sévères au
moment où le retrait des troupes
françaises se termine la france laisse
derrière elle un véritable chaos déclare
ce soir un responsable de msf dans les
camps de réfugiés du zaïre cette fois
chaque jour qui passe n'apporte
malheureusement pas beaucoup d'espoir
d'autant que la saison des pluies vient
de commencer philippe gassot et franck
brice et dans les camps réfugiés la
pluie tombe maintenant tous les jours
les bâches en plastiques ne sont pas
suffisamment nombreuse la nourriture
manque
et le nombre des malades est en
augmentation constante
comme si le choléra et la dysenterie ça
n'était pas assez ici pratiquement aucun
vêtement chaud et sec et encore moins
imperméable les sacs poubelles sont pour
les tout petits une protection inespéré
mais qui le sait et qui s'en soucie la
saison des pluies à quinze jours
d'avancé sur le calendrier et quinze
jours dans de telles conditions c'est
beaucoup les médecins allemands de l'omg
caire commencent aujourd'hui leur
tournée des camps jamais il n'aurait pu
imaginer une situation sanitaire aussi
déplorable les patients se comptent par
milliers et cela ne va pas diminuer
comment espérer qu'il en soit autrement
pieds nus dans l'eau glaciale les
enfants tous déjà comment vous voyez
l'avenir des gens qui vivent dans ce
camp l'avenir se joue ici ce retrait
malgré ces restes ici parce que je n'ai
pas bonnes causes des maladies
je vous promets des dialogues sanglantes
puis l'a tous fait mauvais climat
bon jeu peggle encore là ça évidemment
la malnutrition
ce sera en fait ne les maladies
outre-rhin on a fait appel aux
volontaires
on pratique ici une médecine de guerre
quelques instants par malade mais c'est
tellement mieux que rien les hommes et
les femmes en blanc sont 250 pour la
plupart médecins ou étudiants en
médecine
ils ont été sélectionnés parmi 5000
volontaires à avoir répondu présent ils
ne se doutaient pas d'un tel désastre
ils vont se répartir dans les différents
camps où ils ne sont même plus espérer
car plus le temps passe plus la misère
s'aggrave encore des morts et des
remords la saison des pluies va durer
trois mois